[Musica]
mi chiamo matthias storie o 30 quattro
anni e nella vita faccio politica mi fa
sempre strano dire questa frase
ma mi piace presentarmi così per vedere
l'effetto che fa sugli altri su di voi
ma soprattutto su me stesso
perché il rapporto con la politica per
una persona nata nella mia generazione
diciamo che non è proprio non è mai
stato grosio
ero ancora alle elementari quando
scoppiava tangentopoli in italia e la
folla inviperita lanciava le monetine
contro craxi era il primo anno delle
superiori quando berlusconi firmavo un
finto patto con gli italiani salvo poi
andare a fare le corna in mondovisione
qualche mese successivo
era il primo anno di università e la
caduta del governo prodi veniva
festeggiata con sventolando mortadelle
in parlamento ecco che quindi era molto
difficile per una persona come me per un
giovane dire avrei fatto politica da
grande 6 qualcosa andò storto perché un
giorno con tre amici ci venne un'idea
stavamo per lanciare una delle più
partecipate innovative campagne
elettorali comunicazione politica degli
ultimi anni ma non potevamo saperlo
erano tempi molto bui per la politica in
quel momento
dopo decine di populismo non erano più
le idee i contenuti a contare ma
l'immagine più scabrosa la comunicazione
più aggressiva la strategia più cinica
l'ondata di brutture squallore politico
che aveva invaso l'italia si stava
avvicinando la nostra regione l'emilia
romagna
mancavano poco più di due mesi a quelle
che sarebbero state le elezioni della
nostra regione e decidemmo che non
volevamo che la nostra regione entrasse
in quella spirale in cui erano entrate
altre regioni altri comuni d'italia
nelle tornate elettorali precedente fu
così che decidemmo di coinvolgere di
chiamare in causa la grande assente
della politica italiana fino a quel
momento la cittadinanza attiva
associazioni comitati locali realtà
sociali parrocchie scout bologna come
tante altre città italiane vive di
volontariato e terzo settore senza il
volontariato il terzo settore non ci
sarebbero ospedali non funziona e vero i
doposcuola
non avremo mense e dormitori per i più
fragili non ci sarebbero e polisportive
le scuole di musica com'era possibile
che tutta quella massa di politici fosse
stata esclusa dalla politica com'era
possibile che il linguaggio dolci
accogliente e familiare del volontariato
fosse rimasto fuori e sostituito dalle
bestie social o dell eroe da tastiera fu
così che decidemmo di fare un invito che
sembrava talmente semplice dato a
sembrare un gioco chiedevamo venti
minuti di un giovedì sera qualsiasi e
promettevamo in grande dicevamo che quel
gesto avrebbe rivoluzionato la scena
politica in italia avremmo arginato il
sovrani smo fermo bloccato la retorica
populista
l'unica cosa che chiedevamo le persone
era di scendere in piazza maggiore alla
piazza della città con una sardina in
mano
assurdo
nessuno nessuna bandiera nessun insulto
nessuna violenza questo era lo slogan
semplicissimo solo sardine mood ad
ascoltare quella che sarebbe diventato
un po il manifesto una canzone profetica
com'è profondo il mare di lucio dalla
limiterà assurdo ma la gente reagisce e
si presentò vestita da servire il prezzo
maggiore
una massa di creatività di persone che
non si vedeva da anni
bambini e alla prima la prima
manifestazione della loro vita
pensionati che non venivano in piazza
dal 68 militanti di partito come
cittadini che saranno allontanate dalla
politica nel momento di massima di
massimo pienone della piazza l'ex
assessore al bilancio di bologna sale
sulla torre che domina la piazza e
scatta una foto questa foto
non esisteva la pandemia non erano
vietati gli assembramenti non c'erano
restrizioni
eppure vedere quei corpi fisici reali
che tornavano a prendersi cura della
politica ebbe un effetto inaspettato
ci fu una sorta di risveglio collettivo
una presa di coscienza una voglia di
partecipazione che dilagò in tantissime
città l'italia
modena milano firenze palermo napoli
bari tantissime città furono invase da
queste strane sardina senza che noi
dovessimo fare niente spontaneamente è
andato oltre i confini italiane grazie a
quegli e marge a quelli emigrati
italiani di cui poco parliamo 33 città
europee ed extra europee parteciparono
da gattinara noi o archi immaginate da
sorrento ad amsterdam il format era
talmente semplice il messaggio così
chiaro che partecipare era facilissimo
ovviamente la politica la vecchia
politica non stette a guardare
e iniziò a lanciare insulti e critiche
sentenze
i principali quotidiani nazionali
cercavano a tutti i costi un
finanziatore un manovratore perché era
impossibile che questa maxi operazione
di comunicazione politica non avesse
nessuno dietro la macchina del fango si
intensificò e vi posso assicurare che
per chi come noi non aveva mai fatto
parte della scena mediatica politica fu
molto molto difficile
ma mentre le porte dei giornalisti si
affannavano a cercare un burattinaio le
piazze continuavano a riempirsi in meno
di un mese erano scese in piazza a 300
mila persona in 130 città diverse la
cosa bella è che le persone era tornato
i protagonisti della politica
la cosa brutta che noi non avevamo
nessuna idea di come gestire questo
patrimonio
per fortuna non eravamo soli e
tantissime persone allora sconosciuti
agli amici amiche fraterna ci diedero
una mano perché capirono la tempesta
perfetta che ci aveva travolto
organizziamo così l'ultima grande
manifestazione a roma con la piazza san
giovanni simbolica vennero mezzo milione
di persone 500 mila persone salì sul
palco anche carla nespolo in uno dei
suoi ultimi interventi in pubblico
il giorno dopo ci fu la assemblee la
prima assemblea di tutti quegli
organizzatori organizzatrici di piazza e
che ancora non si erano conosciuti
non potevamo essere più diverse fu un
disastro
giovanissimi pensionati che i cattolici
moderati liberali radicali si interrompa
italiani senza cittadinanza
militanti di partiti e cittadini alla
primissima esperienza politica ci
accorgemmo che il punto in comune che
tutti ci sentivamo emarginati dalla
scena politica
erano stati tagliati fuori chi perché
troppo progressista chi perché
semplicemente non era stato invitato
ci accorgiamo anche che la
contaminazione politica di cui c'eravamo
tanti tanto riempito la bocca era molto
più facile a dirsi che a farsi
tornammo a bologna con la convinzione
che quella diversità doveva tradursi in
un grande concerto in una grande festa
per rappresentare le diverse anime di
questa famiglia
fu così che coinvolgiamo musicisti
cantanti e artisti e personaggi della
cultura ma anche cittadini che ogni
giorno praticavano la loro piccola
resistenza in un paese complesso come
l'italia
non avevamo un soldo ma la
partecipazione fa miracoli
lanciamo una raccolta fondi sotto natale
arriviamo a 70 mila euro e un po che
settimana grazie a quelle tremila
persone che dovranno donarono qualcosa
gratuitamente e grazie soprattutto al
lavoro di andrea roberto e giulia ei
volontari il 19 gennaio 2020 piazza viii
agosto a bologna era così
40.000 persone
c'erano otto gradi di massima
nonostante le sei ore di concerto e il
freddo quasi tutte le persone rimasero
dall'inizio alla fine
dopo anni di lontananza la politica era
tornata essere vicina a scatenare
qualcosa nelle persone che dal palco
raccontavano le proprie storie e da
sotto il palco ascoltavano ballavano
cantavano sentendosi finalmente parte di
un insieme
il giorno delle elezioni a tarda sera
la candidata perdente ammise la propria
sconfitta e stefano bonaccini che vinse
quelle elezioni festeggiò con un post su
facebook quel post fece 32.000 like
anche noi postiamo la foto possiamo la
foto del bagno liberatorio nelle acque
gelide di cervia il nostro post fece
42.000 like
eravamo l'unica forza politica in campo
a non aver speso un euro sui social
media
eppure registravamo performance e tassi
di engagement nettamente superiore a chi
aveva speso decine centinaia di migliaia
di euro
con quel posto annunciamo il nostro
passo di lato
eravamo saliti sul palcoscenico non
perché lo volessimo perché ce n'era
bisogno
ma era tempo di una leadership
collettiva condivisa democraticamente
democraticamente eletta dal basso
così convocammo una sorta di assemblea
costituente per il mese dopo a scampia e
la mia storia dovrebbe finire qui con il
ritorno a una vita normale
un sacco di grane per i nostri
successori
ma non andò così
perché la politica è un organismo
talmente fragile che non lascia decidere
a te
quando ha bisogno
finite le elezioni eravamo diventati
pericolosi scomodi
i sondaggi dicevano che se ci fossimo
candida che avremmo preso un sacco di
voti il problema che questi voti li
avremo rubati a cui partite quelle
realtà politiche che fino a quel momento
ci avevano ritenuto innocui o forse
utili per
fortuna ci pensa la pandemia
a bruciare quel germoglio che era troppo
giovane per resistere alle intemperie
così grande
l'appuntamento che sarà vanno dati a
scampia ovviamente non si poté fare con
lui perdiamo l'occasione di farci dilata
di tornare le nostre mit
gli errori che fino a quel momento
avevamo commesso e ci venivano in
qualche modo per donati non ci furono
più perdonate eravamo giudicati come dei
politici navigati che facevano grossi
scivolone
era come se tutti si fossero dimenticati
che avevamo iniziato a fare politica da
tre mesi
come se non bastasse i nostri amici i
nostri compagni esausti per lo sforzo
umano e lavorativo
stato chiesto abbandonarono la nave
perché capirono che la tempesta sarebbe
durata ancora molto con loro per fortuna
scesero anche tutti quegli arrivisti che
sulla nave si erano saliti per farsi
traghettare verso qualche approdo sicuro
nel frattempo i media avevano deciso che
le sardine erano morte
e poco importa se ogni giorno centinaia
di attivisti tutta italia si sentivano
via col che avessimo lanciato una
campagna di raccolta fondi per
acquistare delle mascherine che avessimo
proposto il reddito di solidarietà per
anticipare quelli storiche non
arrivavano mai
dopo mesi di prime pagine di talk show
di copertina era iniziata la fase
dell'anonimato
che fu una liberazione
perché finalmente non dovevamo fare
quello che il sistema si aspettava che
facessimo ma potevamo essere noi stessi
e tornare sul locale fare quello che ci
piaceva
decidemmo che il lock down con la fine
della town saremmo tornati in piazza ma
questa volta non più quelle persone ma
con le piantine con delle piante e
lanciamo una sfida la città di bologna
48 ore per trasformare 6 mila piantine
in un fondo per la cultura di prossimità
mettevamo a disposizione una piattaforma
web una sorta di crowd funding
interattivo grazie a quaranta attivisti
in bicicletta le piantine arrivavano a
casa delle persone
fu difficilissimo organizzarla il log da
non era ancora realmente finito le
restrizioni erano severissima molto più
diverso
erano i tempi di agile arancione la
tensione nel paese cresceva e noi
decidiamo ancora una volta di fare una
proposta di bellezza in mezzo un paese
sull'orlo della crisi di nervi e fu un
successo anzi fu un mezzo miracolo
polverizzando in 5 ore tutte le piantine
grazie a 4.500 donazione gli ordini
furono talmente veloci che impazzivo per
gestire le consegne il comune di bologna
deciso di raddoppiare la quota
raccogliamo 60 mila euro che si
trasformarono nei mesi successivi in
oltre cento eventi culturali in tutta in
tutta l'estate in quei tempi non si
parlava di crisi della cultura
la protesta dei bauli arriverà solo ad
ottobre successivo ma ne avevamo parlato
con l'allora assessore alla cultura
matteo lepore e ci aveva spiegato che
senza i proventi del turismo
la cultura era in ginocchio
si erano spenti i riflettori mano astrid
e non era cambiata riconoscere l'utilità
della politica ma riconoscerne anche la
fragilità e nella fragilità riconoscere
la complementarietà della società civile
non servono nuovi bravi politici non
servono nuovi cittadini attivi non
servono nuovi partiti ne abbiamo già
tantissime basta cercarle
quello che serve sono cerniere
serve un mondo di mezzo
che mette in comunicazione gli strumenti
del mondo di dentro quegli strumenti che
abbiamo nel mondo di fuori
qualsiasi cosa diventeranno le sardine
io credo che quei tre mesi di passione
di creatività di gratuita abbiano ancora
tanto da insegnare
e quando mi chiedono ancora oggi ma chi
c'era dietro alle sardine io continua a
rispondere che dietro ad essere di ne
saranno quattro amici ex coinquiline che
con la stessa responsabilità con cui si
dividevano i lavori di casa un giorno e
si sono guardati in faccia e si sono
detti la politica non ce la fa diamogli
una mano
e oggi che sono passati due anni mi
ritrovo eletto nel consiglio comunale di
bologna ve lo posso assicurare la
politica da sola non ce la fa
perché la politica è una responsabilità
collettiva
non è un no ion voi un dentro fuori una
croce su una scheda una delega in bianco
per cinque anni
la politica rispetto per la comunità e
cura del territorio e proporre
iniziative
eventi anche servizi
se lasciamo da solo alla politica come
possiamo pretendere che la politica si
prenda cura di noi
un'altra forma di politica esiste e non
bisogna cercarla lontano bisogna
semplicemente smettere di essere attori
ricordarsi che la politica è stata
creata perché fossimo tutti i
protagonisti
grazie
[Applauso]